[Musica]
buonasera e iniziamo subito con un
piccolo quiz provate a calcolare a mente
10 più 229 avete fatto semplice no
provate a farlo adesso
tempo il grande una persona adulta con
sindrome di asperger dice che l'autismo
è come un cesto con molti puzzle diversi
tutti mescolati fra di loro
dove c'è confusione e dove spesso le
cose sono poco chiare
ognuno di noi ha un'idea di autismo che
non è reale perché nessuno di noi sa
com'è davvero essere una persona con
autismo
ma chi sono realmente le persone con
autismo e che cos'è realmente questa
condizione che colpisce un bambino su
100 è prevalentemente i maschi
come vivono la loro vita
proviamo a capirlo attraverso lo sguardo
di paolo adulto di 55 anni con autismo
nell'immaginario collettivo l'autismo è
dipinto così
molti di noi credono che le persone con
autismo non provino emozioni e non siano
empatiche ma è davvero così
sono intensamente empatico e le emozioni
delle persone ne attraversano con fosse
incontrollata
ho imparato presto a muovermi in punta
di piedi a nascondermi perché mostrare
come ero e cosa provavo mi faceva
spaventare molto e non era possibile il
mio mondo era forte intenso ricco di
colori ricchissimo di odori iper
stimolante confuso il mio corpo era
troppo sensibile
assorbivo e percepivo tutto nel bene e
nel male
per anni abbiamo creduto che l'autismo
passasse con la crescita e adesso ma 51
anni ho saputo d'essere asperger e la
confusione che mi portavo dietro da anni
è svanita come neve al sole e portando
pace e riposo
continuerò a dubitare di quello che
valgo a sentirmi a disagio accanto ai
colleghi a non sapere cosa ci si aspetta
da me ma non sapere cosa sia opportuno
dire o non dire in determinate
situazioni a detestare il telefono a
dimenticarmi di tutto e di tutti quando
mi concentro
spesso pensiamo che le persone con
autismo abbiano pochi interessi ma
disegnare scrivere e recitare ecco cosa
mi piace fare quando non lavoro
dopo aver disegnato mi sento molto
meglio
mi piace recitare perché ho
l'opportunità di mettermi nei panni
degli altri
a volte crediamo che le persone con
autismo non provino interesse per gli
altri in classe non partecipavo mai
attivamente per difficoltà non per
mancato interesse e quindi passavo
sempre per quello che non era
interessato agli argomenti o agli altri
in realtà facevo molta fatica a fare
nuove amicizie anche se lo desideravo
tanto
per molti anni ci hanno fatto credere
che l'autismo fosse una malattia non
sono una persona malata anche se per
tanti anni mi sono sentito tale dare un
nome alle mie caratteristiche mi ha
permesso di capire che funziona solo in
un modo diverso
i falsi miti si basano su pre giudizi
cioè su giudicare prima prima di
conoscere prima di sapere prima di
analizzare
la scienza ci permette di imparare di
comprendere di raggio di studiare di
sperimentare la scienza ci guida è una
luce che illumina so che difficilmente
potremmo vedere le i gay è la scienza
che si occupa di analizzare il
comportamento umano e iniesta per up
live behavioral analysis che tradotto in
maniera letterale significa analisi
applicata del comportamento e la scienza
che studia le leggi che regolano il
comportamento umano e insieme ad altri
interventi che hanno evidenza
scientifica è uno dei tasselli di un
grande puzzle che attraverso la
conoscenza del comportamento umano ci
aiuta e si occupa di osservare o
comprendere ed approfondire il
comportamento delle persone con autismo
ci fa indossare degli occhiali che ci
fanno vedere con occhi più sinceri più
puliti liberi da pregiudizi
gli interventi con evidenza scientifica
sono più di uno e ci aiutano a
comprendere un mondo sottile e delicato
e fragile un mondo in cui bisogna
entrare in punta di piedi
l'analisi del comportamento ci permette
di supportare e sostenere le persone con
diagnosi di autismo di insegnare loro
alcuni comportamenti che possono essere
utili per farle sentire maggiormente
integrate nel nostro contesto sociale
per farle sentire meno soli supporta le
persone con autismo affinché possano
essere più autonomi a comunicare anche
se non emettono suoni per che imparano a
dialogare attraverso le immagini
attraverso i gesti insegna loro a
prendere l'autobus oppure a cercare un
nuovo posto di lavoro
ecco questi sono solo alcuni esempi di
nuovi apprendimenti
le pieghe è solo un tassello fra tanti
il tassello di un mosaico formato da
molte altre discipline che negli anni
occupate di autismo
vi racconto adesso la storia di andrea
andrea a 8 anni e una diagnosi grave di
autismo
andrea non sa allacciarsi le scarpe
eppure allacciarsi le scarpe è molto
semplice ma siamo sicuri che per una con
autismo sia così semplice
andrea attraverso gli strumenti e le
tecniche delle idee e l'ha imparato un
passo alla volta
concludiamo questo dialogo con una
riflessione di paolo che ci dice quando
ho incontrato una persona con autismo
abbiate pazienza molta pazienza anche di
più di quella che avete sono persone con
autismo non capisce subito quello che
gli stati dicendo
provatelo
a spiegare un modo più chiaro magari
utilizzando altre parole magari
utilizzando delle immagini o
semplicemente da un altro punto di vista
non giudichiamo quindi cambiamo il
nostro sguardo perché il mondo ha
bisogno di tutti i tipi di mente
[Applauso]
[Musica]